former minneapolis police officer derek
showman found guilty of murder and
manslaughter and george floyd's death
business insider story okay
he was found guilty of second-degree
murder third degree murder and
manslaughter in the death of george
floyd floyd died on may 25th after
chauvin a
minneapolis police officer at the time
knelt on his neck for
nine minutes eight minutes and 46
seconds to be exact during an arrest
chauvin faces up to 40 years in prison
for second degree murder
25 years for third degree and 10 years
for second degree manslaughter because
of chauvin
because sheldon was convinced and
convicted of all the charges he will be
sentenced on
the top charge of second degree murder
jurors deliberate deliberated
for a total of nine hours and 45 minutes
before the court announced they
had a verdict okay then tucker carlson's
reaction to derek shawn's
conviction was to cast doubt on jurors
who decided to murder
him heard murder george floyd after the
conclusion of derek chovan
murder trial tucker carlson's reaction
tuesday night was a question
the jury's motivation in reaching its
guilty verdict a few hours earlier
a jury of five men and seven women
returned to unanimous guilty verdict on
all three counts
against chauvin in the death of george
floyd carson carlson
characterized the verdict not as
impartial decision based on trial but
rather the jurors
way of saying please don't hurt us it
was part of a longer opening monologue
suggesting that the jurors were spurred
by fear of writing by people who have
been angered
by a verdict of not guilty can we trust
the way this decision was made he asked
so
having said that what are your thoughts
on what took place
the last 24 hours adam i'll go to you
first and i'll come to ricky
well i think um
i agree with this decision let's just
start with the the the basics here
i think um the guy
chauvin put his knee on george floyd's
neck and murdered the man people want to
say well he had drugs in his system or
well
you know he wasn't a great father that's
not a reason to [ __ ] to die
okay so anyone who has two eyeballs and
a brain and a heart will realize
yeah chauvin definitely played a part
now if you're part of the
chauvin's defense or if you want to be
the tucker carlson and you want to kind
of play both sides you can say
well how much of a cause was it was it
definitely
but i'm just gonna side with the jury
here and say yes guilty homie go to jail
but bigger bigger than than this
is i think something that the democrats
did
in the election in 2020 was coin the
phrase defund the police i personally
think that's not a smart move
i think we need more police or better
trained police
i think the slogan should be de-escalate
the police not defund the police
de-escalate the police because everyone
who has an interaction with the police
these days especially black people that
[ __ ] gets escalated so quick
even yesterday uh a girl i don't know
what happened with that we could talk
about that
as well yeah but like why is everything
with the police
you know kill or be killed and kneeling
on the neck and killing the guy
or shooting person or someone's running
away you shoot him in the back
police i think there was a lady on bill
maher she was a journalist who actually
in her 40s became a police officer
and had to go through the training and
basically
commented on what police have to deal
with she said they're asked to do too
much
she said there has to be social workers
they're asked to be medics they're act
to be
they're asked to be heroes and warriors
and negotiators and everything they're
doing that and
all at the you know ripe age of 25 years
old either any of those jobs
is very hard to do any of those jobs to
do whether you're a nurse
an emt a negotiator social worker now
you're going to throw on top of that a
badge and a gun for someone who's
fresh out of you know not college but
college age they're asked to do too much
so
you throw a badge and a gun on them and
they get on a power trip we've all dealt
with police who's
been on a power trip so i think
look george floyd at the end of the day
was a martyr he was a symbol he was a
lightning rod he wasn't a hero
okay he he was a guy who had some issues
in his life
that happened to be at the wrong place
at the wrong time and had a knee on his
neck
and it went viral because everybody's
got a phone in their hands these days
and people are saying bro you're killing
him he's shouting out i can't breathe
he's calling for his mother anyone who
watched that
you'd have no heart to not sympathize
with what he was going through whether
he was on drugs or not
so you know what what carlson is also
looking to do because he brought up
tucker carlson he's basically saying
that
whether you like this or not derek
shovin was also a martyr
now why was he a martyr because let's
say just for a second hypothetically
that he actually didn't kill george
floyd let's just say that for a second
let's just say for whatever reason
he didn't really kill him and have his
knee on his neck
he's a martyr because do you know what
would have happened in this country
if he was actually found innocent of all
charges
burn this [ __ ] to the ground
okay how bad do you think it would have
been
bader than you think like way worse
every major
rodney king rodney king was in la in one
city this is a national thing think
about
it in the middle of a freaking pandemic
yeah everyone in the country you know
blm
i get it you know people basically said
this is more important this is a reason
for me to leave my house
take off my freaking mask and get out
there and riot and and
i would you know they say you know 99 of
the people the riots are
uh marching or was was peaceful i get it
the protest i get it
there were definitely some disgusting
looting and stuff that like that's going
on so
in my opinion george floyd was not a
hero but he is a symbol of
um accountability and
derek chovin also is a martyr whether
you like that or not but
um i think my my final point here is one
thing for sure is
de-escalate the police they have way too
much power they're asked to do too much
and they're not supposed to be doing at
the end of the day they're
they're supposed to um
they're no one's above the law including
law enforcement officers they're
supposed to
protect the peace and a lot of times and
i get that 90 percent of cops 99 of cops
are good
but they have so it's so tough to be a
cop you say that the like how hard is it
to be a
job today so hard to be a cop right now
be anything but a cop today
but i don't think that's i think
that we can have a pause and reset
moment and the police
because police don't forget people on
trial at the trial
yeah also said yeah he murdered him
police said that
police said that so when you have police
kind of ratting on your own
i think you know that you did something
wrong so uh ricky what are you thinking
uh you know pat i'm gonna be honest with
you i i'm a little bit i'm a little bit
uh
i'm split on this um i don't like to
argue points just to argue them
uh i don't like to be uh irrational i'm
very i'm a very logical person when it
comes out to things like this
here's here's a reality behind things
during
the okay
i grew up in the hood okay me and all of
my friends have been arrested either
once or multiple times and we've had
interactions with cops
i'm gonna tell you a quick story i it's
two in the morning
i'm coming home from dinner but shout
out to pamila samaria which has been my
childhood friend of mine
and she works with us right now in in in
within our within our team
and we're going home okay well she gets
pulled over i'm not even driving
she gets pulled over and they run her
name everything's good well the cop
asked me what's your name
keep in mind i'm 19 years old i already
had a record by this time actually yeah
19 or 20 years old they pull my name
another cop pulls up
right so he pulls my name goes back into
his car says wait here
another actually two more cups pull up
because my name was pulled
okay this was 13 14 years ago
then they said get out of the car and
there's three cops waiting you know
outside okay cool
where are you going where are you coming
from you get out yeah i get out of the
car that's okay
so here's a reality behind things
whether we like to admit it or not
okay whenever they ran his name
they realized he's been in prison more
than once and he put a gun
to the stomach of a pregnant woman while
they were robbing
so whenever you run somebody's name
and you see what they're capable of your
natural instincts are to tighten up
and to be a little bit more aggressive
with the person because you know that
they are naturally aggressive
yeah i can't breathe yeah he cried for
his mom and that's horrible to listen to
as a human being
right and there's no way to excuse that
because at that point your your humanity
has to come out and say you know what
something's wrong here if this person's
you know crying out that much
you already got them in handcuffs maybe
chill a little bit okay maybe
you got him this you guys got this gonna
say surrounded he doesn't have a gun on
him yeah he
you got him like chill if this guy's
crying out chill
but but on the other hand
they had a different angle which the
news never put out
where uh chavin what's his name chavin
chauvin had his had his knee on his back
and not on his neck
so we're looking at a viewpoint down
where he's looking at the camera where
we see a knee and we see the guy's back
but we don't see
specifically where his knee is at even
though it looks like he's on his neck
well the reason that they were thinking
of quitting him is because they actually
had his he had his knee
on his back not on his neck now we had
this discussion you're like
well we don't know that well we don't
know that he had it on his leg either
that's the truth now is it unfortunate
that he died
yes is it is there any way to excuse
that
no now that trauma had anything to do
with killing him here's a reality
you don't know that neither do i we do
know that he was high on fentanyl
i'm very familiar with drugs because i
grew up in a drug-infested neighborhood
which
my city is one of the capital cities for
the cartels in the united states
that's where they're stationed a lot of
them are at and that's where they
distribute from so we're very familiar
with i grew up around it
we sold it we bought it we used it
that's just the reality behind the very
very transparent
i know what happens to your heart rate
when you're on drugs you're it's not
meant for you to be in a situation where
you're
where you're where you could get even
more your heart rate goes even more up
because you can have a heart attack
i've had friends overdose i had there's
in my neighborhood
there was three brothers with all three
of them overdosed on cocaine not on
fentanyl
nobody was around them and by the way
that's one of people i got stories like
that for days
i have many of my close friends overdose
on cocaine which is nowhere near like
fentanyl
no it's not even a quarter of it so when
you're putting they just they just they
just overdosed
right and so when you have fentanyl
which right now as a matter of fact when
they're cooking this stuff they put
gloves on pat
they put gloves on like the people that
are cooking it because it's that
dangerous
they literally wear suits you know uh
biohazard suits
when they're making it in mexico in the
in the in the in the
what are they called in the lab in the
lab okay
in the kitchen in the kitchen so when
you're consuming that [ __ ]
and to think that the most dangerous
drug in america right now
had nothing to do with this death is
simply insane
you're you're naive you do not know how
drugs work
if you could overdose on cocaine you can
overdose on meth
fentanyl is by far it's ten times worse
than both of those drugs combined
so to think that that didn't play a role
it's just ridiculous now is it okay no
do i i'm just split on it i'm not going
to take one set or the other
anything could have happened anything
could happen do you trust the justice
system
no hell no no you don't trust the
justice system no no way so let me ask
you what do you trust more politicians
or the justice system
uh if i had to choose between both
maybe the justice system but not
politicians got it so it's because let
me tell you why yeah
because if i have the money to hire a
lawyer the lawyer's gonna get me out of
it okay
so i can buy you can buy a politically
talked about yesterday one of your
lawyers in australia who
you know he's gonna talk about he says
every client of mine they're all
criminals they're all you know all this
other stuff but if they got the money i
can uh
help them out right okay so you you
trust the justice system more than you
trust
uh politicians yes on both sides by the
way okay how much do you think
how much do you think these jurors made
the decision
based on facts and what happened and how
much you think the decision was based on
when the president is calling you
telling you we hope that you make the
right decision
and maxine waters is calling they don't
want to be the cause of riots all over
the country
the president wasn't calling the jurors
bro the jury i mean if you call them
if you believe in impartial who calls
the jury and who calls them no nobody's
calling the
called the jury nobody asked the jurors
to make the right decision nobody did
are you sure i would i hope not
would you like to pull it up hold it up
sure i don't know what you're talking
about i think
it's calling all right can we go forward
where uh where biden asked the george to
make the right decision uh
are you serious you're talking about a
public speech bro what are you talking
about are you talking about the public
are you serious right now i can't
believe that if you actually show me a
[ __ ] public speech right now i'm
going to get verified
for you did he call him are you called
up the jurors are what are you saying
right now i didn't pray
brighton uh trades lightly in comments
lightly on comments come on
come on tread lightly there's no
lightning with biting you guys an idiot
bro
traveling trial is jury deliberates
president joe biden waited carefully
into a discussion about murder trial
hold on bro derrick chavin and dave
driving attorneys
right so he's talking about he's hoping
they give the right verdict
also when you say this publicly he's not
going to weigh on a juror that's nobody
compared to the president united states
of america
which they know
what do you think what do you think
about this yeah so but here's what i'm
here's what i'm asking but first of all
maxine waters said
what would her comments if if the trials
doesn't go the way it's supposed to be
we need to be
confrontational at the highest level
guards were shot that day yeah
to a confrontational so so here's here's
what's going on
do you want to be part of that pat do
you want to be part of the country
correct me if i'm wrong you're not
allowed to listen to the news you're not
allowed to be following this kind of
stuff that's kind of the whole part of
it
by the way i want everybody listeners to
realize i'm not speculating that a phone
call was made to anybody i'm not
speculating i know i've interviewed a
lot of mobsters
and the mobsters know how to get a hold
of the jurors okay if monsters know how
to get a hold of jurors i promise you
politicians are going to get a hold of
jurors so
if a sammy gravano knows how to get a
juror to help out god he never you know
other people can do the same but let's
set that aside i don't even want to go
in that direction
all i'm asking is you're one of the 12.
you're one of you know
you're sitting there with the jurors yes
you're asking the group
doors closed nine hours on something
what is it nine hours and 45 minutes
whatever the timeline was right there
and making the decision right you're
sitting there
is anyone asking what the hell is going
to happen to america if we let this guy
go a hundred percent
you think someone asked that nine hours
and what do you think do you think
somebody said oh
it's going to be crazy so do you think
it was
one of those things where they don't
want to be a part of that
do you think it's one of those things
that where one person's life
is less important than us having rights
is that the right way of thinking no
okay so so
i think it is okay you think it is how
okay so tell me why if it was your life
would you want that
you want me to sacrifice you you didn't
do nothing wrong if i'm
if number one i think the jury actually
you want to be a roman in the days of
jesus
actually that crucified jesus just for
the hell of it right you'd be that
person
you're out of control bro i'm just
telling you
so do you think the conversation was
brought up okay listen
let's just relax for a second i think
the jury
actually sat there it's very easy to be
like oh i think this bro and i think
this bro
bro and this is what i think bro i think
i actually
think that they actually sat there and
listened to all the experts that were
called in
for days and days and days and weeks and
they and when an expert says yes
if someone has a knee on your neck and
this is what happens to the heart
and the heart and the palpitations you
gotta understand the centrifugal force
and like
they actually sit there and listen to
the science
for days i think they say how much did
they had a video where he had his knee
on his back
they didn't they watched that youtuber i
don't know where ricky gets his name how
much
how much of the decision how much of the
decision you think was justice how much
of the decision was
america is going to be so flippant
divided it's going to be insane
i think that's what i think the large
percentage of it was
actual the facts of the case i do okay
so you're putting it more there
okay beyond okay i also think that there
was
an emotional component to saying you
know what
don't forget they all have to agree i
mean if the one dissents
yeah then the whole thing is a hung jury
so i think there's probably
like we talked about lo you know logic
and emotion i think there's someone
who's thinking you know what
i don't know but i'm not you know what
sacrificed the sacrificial lamb chauvin
i'm not trying to see america burn i'm
sure people think like that
and you know what i'm okay with it in
this case so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye